[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه معكم ابرز المستجدات وفي العناوين
صواريخ روسيه
في ايران تخطط ال 500 بينهم 69
رئيس تونس يتهم اطرافا بالتامر والغنوش
امام جهات التحقيق في قضيه الجهاد السري
للاخوان
يقدم حكومته الجديده للبرلمان اليوم
للمصادقه بعد اربع سنوات من التجاذبات
السياسيه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا البدايه من الحرب
الاوكرانيه والحجمات الصاروخيه الروسيه
التي طالت عده
في البلاد ضربه صاروخيه روسيه
عنيفه وتسجيل عده انفجارته واشارت تقارير
الى ان الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه اسقطت
خمس صواريخ الروسيه بل خمسه صواريخ روسيه
فوق ميكو لايف هو صاروخان اخر في صومي
بدوره قال مستشار رئاسه الاوكرانيه ان
روسيا اطلقت قرابه 120 صاروخا على مناطق
مختلفه من اوكرانيا اليوم وتصدت الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه للعديد من هذه الصواريخ
كما تم تفعيل حاله الانذار وسمعه دولي
انفجارات في العاصمه افادت وسائل الاعلام
المحليه اوكرانيه عن وقوع عده انفجار في
مدن ليبرو وانيكو بول وسومي وخاركيبر كما
اطلقت صفاره الانذار خلال ساعات الصباح
الباكر في مناطق ايكو لايف وسياس كاسي
وجيتومي محليه
مشاهدينا امريكيه ينضم الينا الكاتب
الصحفي محمد البابا اهلا بك سيد بابا معنا
في هذه النشره وما مدى تاثير هذه الضربه
الصاروخيه على الارض
لم نشهد اي تاثير كبير ولكن في العاصمه
الالكترونيه كيف تم يعني قطع تيار كهربائي
تحسبا يعني عند الساعه 6:00 صباحا تحسبا
لضربات الصاروخيه بعد ما دورت صفارات
الانذار عند الساعه السادسه وخمس دقائق
وبدات هي الانذار بشكل جدي ان روسيا تحذر
لاطلاق صواريخ وعند السادسه والنصف سجل
الاطلاق اكثر من 120 صاروخ حسب ارسال
الرسل شباب موديلات
عند الساعه الثامنه بعد الثامنه بدات تسمع
في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف اصوات انفجارات
عنيفه بينها انفجارات لتصدي الدفاعات
الجويه ل همم يعني الصواريخ وحتى فوق راسي
يعني قبل حوالي 10 دقائق الدفاعات الجويه
استطعت اصابه صاروخين كانها متجهين الى
وسط العاصمه الاوكرانيه
يعني في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف وفيده عن
سقوط صاروخين على مبنى سكني في منطقه دار
ايون ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم يسجل او لم
يتم اعلان اين سقطت الصواريخ في محيط
العاصمه الاوكراني كيف حيث تصنع كما قلت
بين الحين والاخر اصوات انفجارات بعض
الاحيان يقال انها يعني دفاعات جويه تتصدى
الصواريخ وبعدها يقال انها صواريخ سقطت في
مناطق عده لم يتم تحديد اماكنها عاده يعني
خلال الفتره الماضيه همم ادارات المحليه
والادارات العسكريه تتسمون عن طبيعه
الاهداف التي يتم استهدافها ولكن كان هناك
موقف فيه في ايطاليا الذي دعى المواطنين
الى يعني
المحموله والتخسيس المياه خوفا من ارتفاع
للتيار الكهربائي
على شاشه العربيه مصدر العربيه يتحدث عن
همم انقطاع التيار الكهربائي في العاصمه
كيف هل يحدث هذا كيجراءان احترازي ام
النتيجه ده في منشات كهربائيه او منشات
طاقه في المدينه
لان شركه الكهرباء اقفلت جزء كبير من
العاصمه الاوكرانيه يفتح بثوبا لتعرض يعني
هنا تحتيه وبناء الطاقه لضربات صاروخيه في
بعض الاحيان عندما يتم استهداف يتم هناك
تشويش وضرب لمستوى التيار ما يسبب الى
مشاكل داخل المنازل من يعني التلفزيونات
والبرا لكن ذلك شركه الكهرباء تحثنا تعمل
الى قطع التيار الكهربائي قبل سقوط
الصواريخ
الطاقه لم يسجل في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
او لم يعلن رسميا عن استهداف محطات للطاقه
عمده يعني
هناك عده صواريخ اثار او ان العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف تعرضت لسقوط عده صواريخ
ولكن لم يحدد طبيعه الاهداف يعني الفرق
الاسعاف قالت ان هناك نتيجه
صاروخين ايضا يعني مدينه في غرب اوكرانيا
بالقرب من الحدود
الحدود الروسيه عمده مدينتها قال ان وسط
المدينه تعرض لسقوط صواريخ وانقطع التيار
الكهربائي بشكل كامل عن تلك المدينه بعد
سقوط الصواريخ طيب محمد هل يتعاطى السكان
بصوره عامه بمسؤوليه وبجديه كافيه مع هذه
الغارات لان هناك تحذيرات عده من السلطه
الاوكرانيه لاحظناها يطالبون فيها السكان
بالتعامل بجديه مع التحذيرات التي تطلقها
السلطات
يعني حتى يمكن رؤيا ان الشوارع شبه خالي
يعني في هذه المنطقه هناك حركه كثيفه
للسكان بشكل يومي ولكن عند يعني اليوم
هناك التزام كبير يعني نرى يعني حركه
المرور او خروج السكان خجوله فقط لمن لديه
عمل يستطيع الخروج بينما السكان العاديين
الان يقيمون
بعد يعني اشارات لذلك جديه في التعامل
عندما تتعرض العاصمه الاوكرانيه او حتى
معظم المدن الاوكرانيه اضافه الى
التحضيرات التي ممكن عبر الاداره العسكريه
الادارات المحليه تدعوا السكان للالتزام
المداجئ بشكل الفوري وذلك حفاظ على شكرا
لك من كيفكم الصحفي محمد البابا تحياتي
مشاهدينا في سياق اخر اعلنت القياده
الجنوبيه بالجيش الاوكراني ان البحريه
الروسيه نشرت حامله صواريخ هو غواصه
اضافيه في مهمات قتاليه في البحر الاسود
وقالت في بيان انها تحذر سكان الجنوب
اوكرانيا من ان حامله الصواريخ علمتني
اكثر من 20 صاروخا من طراز كاليبر جاهزه
الاطلاقاني الى انها فعلت حاله الانذار
الجويه لتصدي لها هذا هو اعلن وزير التحول
الرقمي
سيارات مقاتله خلال العام المقبل
تتلقى بدايه العام المقبل نماذج جديده من
سيارات القتاليه لها القدره على اسقاط
مسيره الاخرى في الجو فضلا عن كونها ستجمل
وسيارات متفجره واخرى قادره على الطيران
للمسافات لتراوح بين ثلاثه وعشره
كيلومترات
اذا مشاهدينا من التطورات الميدانيه الى
التراشق الدبلوماسي الروسي الاوكراني حيث
قال وزير الخارجيه الروسي يسجل هفرات ان
بلاده تريد حل الوضع في اوكرانيا وانهاء
الحرب في اقرب وقت ممكن
ايضا ان حمايه ارواح الجنود والمدنيين تعد
اولويه بالنسبه الى موسكو وانها تود تسويه
الوضع في اقرب وقت ممكن وضعف ان روسيا ليس
لديها رغبه في اجراء محادثات مع الغرب
خاصه
ان بلاده تم ابلاغها عبر قنوات دبلوماسيه
انه واشنطن لا تعتزموا القتال مباشره معها
لا تقول انها تعتزم تعزيزا نهج التصعيد
نحن مصممون على ضمان تحقيق اهداف العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه
هي المناطق الاربعه الجديده في الاتحاد
الروسي يجب تحري من التهديدات والممارسات
الانتقاميه من الواضح انك ياب ليست مستعده
للحوار كل الافكار وصيغ السلام التي
يطرحها زيرنسكي مجرد وهم يسعى لتحقيقه
بمساعده الغرب شروط مثل انسحاب قواتنا من
اراضي دمباز روسيه وشبه جزيره القرمطه
زبرجيا وخيرس ودفع تعويضات من جانب روسيا
والاستسلام للمحاكم الدوليه وما الى ذلك
جميع هذه الشروط المسبقه غير مقبوله ولن
نتحدث مع اي شخص بشانها
الى الدعم الفرنسي للعاصمه كييف حيث تعهد
وزير الدفاع الفرنسي سباستيانو خلال
زيارته للمره الاولى الامريكيه تعاهد
بتقديم المزيد من المساعدات الاخرانيه
بقيمه 200 مليون يورو لتربيه الاحتياجاتها
العسكريه في الاسابيع المقبله كما نخش
الجانبان مشكله اصلاح المعدات العسكريه
الغربيه التي تضررت في ساحه المعركه
والمساعده
في مواجهه المسيرات الايرانيه
من باريس مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه يحسن اقنيبر اهلا بك حسين وما اهم
ما صدر من تصريحاتنا رسميه حول زياره
وزاره الدفاع الفرنسيه الى كيف
اهلا بك احمد اخر ما صدر في هذا المجال
كان تصريحات ادلى بها وزير الدفاع الفرنسي
سباستيان لقرن هذا الصباح عندما قال انه
التقى الرئيس ازيلنسكي في قصر رئاسيه
محميه جدا تشعر وانك في هذا القصر تشعر
انك في بلد يعيش حربا بدلنسكي انه قائد
بلد يعيش حربا اكد وزير الدفاع الفرنسي
انه يدرس احتمال تقديم المزيد من
المساعدات العسكريه اللي اوكرانيا خلال
الاسابيع المقبله واوضح انه كل فامنا
رئيسين مكرونه
وتسريع المساعدات العسكريه اوضح ايضا ان
بلاده تتحدث عن ضروره صيانه المعدات
الحربيه التي تقدم لاوك لان هناك مشكله
الصيانه وهذه ورشه حقيقيه كان وزير الدفاع
الفرنسي اتحدث للعربيه مؤخرا فقال اننا
امام ورشه حقيقيه تتعلق بتدريب القوات
الاوبرانيه ليس فقط على القتال وانما ايضا
على كيفيه استخدامها هذه المعدات الحربيه
التي نرسلها اليها وايضا كيفيه صيانتها
اذا اتعطلت بالعوده الى زيارته وما صرح به
وما قيل على هامش هذه الزياره ما يدرس
حاليا هو احتمال ان تقدم الصواريخ من طراز
ميلان وميسترا المزيد منها الى اوكرانيا
في الاسابيع المقبله واحتمال تقديم اليات
مصفحه من طراز وايضا مدافع سيدار الشهيره
التي قدمت فرنسا منها سابقا 18 مدفعا هناك
احتمال لان يقدم ما بين سته الى 12 مدفع
سعر 150
يصل مداها الى حواله 40 كيلو متر يمكن ان
تقدم خلال الاشهر المقبله لتضاف الى 18
مدفعا التي قدمت سابقا احمد اذا سكتفي معك
بهذا القدر شكرا لك من باريس كنت معنا
مراسل العربيه حسين قنيبر شكرا على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل
ضخمه من اجل بلدنا وفي هذا التوقيت الصعب
من التحديات المتعلقه
قامت به فرنسا يعد لفته مهمه من جانبها
اشكرهما على المساعدات العسكريه المتمثله
في انظمه صواريخ وانظمه مدفعيه اخرى
اللهم صل الله تعمل الولايات المتحده على
منع ايرام مساعده روسيا في حرب اوكرانيا
وتقول صحيفه نيو تايمز حين واشنطن تتبع
اسلوب العقوبات بشكل خاص لوصول الى نتائج
ايجابيه تغيير في الغانم من واشنطن
اكدت المتحدثه باسم مجلس الامن القومي ان
الولايات المتحده ابحث عن اساليب لمواجهه
انتاج ايران للمسيرات وذلك من خلال
العقوبات ومنع التصدير والتحدث الى
الشركات التي تستعمل ايران قطاعها في
الانتاج هذا التصحيح يدل اولا على ان
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها لن يتمكنوا من
فرض حصار بالقوه يمنع ايران من مساعده
روسيا في حرب اوكرانيا
لكنها لم تمنع استمرار ايران في انتاج
مسيرات الكثير من هذه التكنولوجيا والقطاع
استعمالها مزدوج ومن المستحيل ومنع ايران
من الحصول عليها
التحدي الاكبر الذي تواجه الولايات
المتحده هو ان صناعه المسيرات الايرانيه
تستعمل قطعا متوفره في الاسواق العالميه
لوضعها على محركات المسيره وغالبيه القطاع
من اشباه الموصلات والمحركات الصغيره
متوفره للهواه وتمكن الايرانيون من لهاء
الى اسلحه
من المستحيل تقريبا منع موده تجاريه من
الوصول الى يد الطرف الذي لا ترغب به
المره الاولى التي تم فيها الحديث عن هذه
المشكله كان في تقرير لمؤسسه امريكيه
بدايه الخريف الماضي وقالت ان القطاع
تستوردها ايران من النمسا والمانيا
وبريطانيا والولايات المتحده
من الاستيراد من الاسواق الغربيه لكن
التحدي الاكبر يعود الى اسواق الصين ربما
لا تستطيع الولايات المتحده ايران من
تصنيع المسيارات والصواريخ وسيكون على
واشنطن وحلفائها تعزيز المساعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا خصوصا المضادات الجويه وهي تفعل
الكثير من ذلك الان نجم مصر خاصه
يبلغ ثمنها اربعه الاف دولار اوكرانيا
تحتاج الى اعتاد للدفاع عن بنيتها التحتيه
والمدنيين خصوصا الاسلحه قصيره المدى
والاقل تماما هناك اساليب كثيره في لعبه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لمساعدته
اوكرانيا لكن المشكله لدى واشنطن هو ان
ايران اخذت جانب روسيا وسيكون من المستحيل
على طهران ان تغير موقفه في الغنم العربيه
واشنطن
تواجه فنلندا ازمه في نقص دادات الكهرباء
وارتفاع اسعارها وذلك منذ قطع العلاقات في
مجالات الطاقه مع جارتها روسيا على خلفيه
محاوله انضمامها الى جانب السويد لحلف
الناتو وفي ظل الانقطاع المتكرر الكهربائي
عن المنازل في فصل الشتاء يواصل البحث عن
حلول للازمه
تداعيات ازمه الطاقه بين اوروبا وروسيا
تشتد في فصل الشتاء
وفنلندا الطامحه للانضمام
باهظ لمسعها
مواطن الدوله
للحطب كمصدر للتدفئه وهربا من اسعار
الطاقه
من الحطب الان 220 يورو بعدما كان يتراوح
بين 85 الى 90 يورو قبل الازمه
رحله البحث عن حلول بديله داخل منازل
الفلنديين لا تتوقف لا سيما بعدما تضاعفت
اسعار الكهرباء على المستهلكين من السكان
قوطه من خلال حرق الاخشاب نقوم بتسخين
المكان قبل ان تنخفض درجه الحراره الى ما
دون الصفر كثير من الناس في وضع سيء
للغايه وعليهم التفكير في كيفيه بقائهم
على قيد الحياه لان كل شيء اصبح اكثر كلفه
تهديدات موسكو لهلسنكي اصبحت واقعا وبعد
ما اعتمدت فنلندا على الثلاثي طاقتها من
روسيا الان تقترب من الرقم صفر امام وزاره
الشؤون الاقتصاديه الفنديه فلا تتوقف عن
تحذير مواطنها من تكرار انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي
الاقليميه والمناطق الاصغر سيعمم فيها
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي مع تحذير
لمواطنين مسبقا
تخزين المشاعل ومضخاته الحراره والالواح
الشمسيه ثم اللجوء الى الحطب جميعها مشاهد
تعكس واقع ازمه الطاقه في فنلندا لكنها
تعكس واقعا اكثر قتامه لانه منه
الفنلنديون منذ قطع العلاقات في مجالات
الطاقه مع الجاره روسيا على اثر الصراع مع
اوكرانيا
علي السمان العربيه
بلغت حصيله ضحايا الاحتجاجات في ايران
588 اشخاص العداد صدرت من موقع هيرانه
حقوق الانسان في ايران
66 شخصا من قوات الامن ايضا الموقع ذكر ان
عدد الضحايا تحت سن الثامنه عشر بلغ تسعه
وستين بالاضافه لاعتقال اكثر من ثمانيه
عشر الف شخصا بينهم
667 طالبا يتوسع الى ان تحرك اطلقته
مجموعه من النواب الالمان قبل بدعه اسابيع
برعايه السجناء السياسيين في ايران
العربيه بان قرابه
برعايه السجناء في ايران وان هناك
الاوروبيه يريدون القيام بخطوه مماثله
اكثر من 100 نائبا الماني اصبح رعاه
لسجناء سياسيين في ايران في الايام
الماضيه التحرك الذي بدا صغيرا مع عدد من
النواب من الحزب الاشتراك الحاكم توسع
كثيرا في الايام الماضيه يقولوا لنا كيف
منصور
الرعايه السياسيه تعني الاهتمام بقضيه
السجناء والتعامل مع المحاكمات الصواريه
التي يتعرضون لها في ايران
الايراني لان ما يحصل حاليا هناك من
محاكمات سوريه لا علاقه له باي شيء يتعلق
بحكم القانون وقد لاحظنا في الايام
الماضيه ان الضغوط على ايران تحدث فرقا
وهي غالبا تساعد منصوري واسنانه واربعون
نائبا اخر من حزبه وقعوا وثيقه تطالب
الحكومه بالتشدد اكثر مع النظام الايراني
لتقول الحكومه انه قرار يتخذ داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي
هو الاهم والاكثر رمزيه ولكن يعتقد انه
يجب اتباعه بعقوبات اضافيه ضد منهم في
السلطه في ايران واعتقد ان الخطوه التاليه
يجب ان تستهدف النواب الايرانيين المئتين
227 ومن له يدوم في اعدام متظاهرين من
قضاه ومدعي وغيرهم وهذا يبعث برساله واضحه
اننا لن نتغاضى عن جرائم ضد حقوق الانسان
موقف وزيره الخارجيه التي تتحدث من بدايه
التظاهرات عن مساء الاوروبيه لاضافه
الحارس السوري للائحه الارهاب هذا التحرك
الذي يشهده البرلمان الالماني وصل صده الى
برلمانات اوروبيه اخرى في فرنسا وبريطانيا
والسويد وغيرها من الدول التي يتواصلوا
نوابها مع نواب الالمان لمعرفه كيفيه ايه
سجناء في ايران راغده بعنام العربيه بلين
ايران اتخذت قرار استراتيجيا لتعزيز
تواجدها في قطاع الطاقه العراقي حيث
افتتحت وزاره النفط الايرانيه مكتبا
تمثيليه لها في بغداد المصادر قالت ان
الخطوه الايرانيه تاتي ضمن سلسله خطوات
بهدف تعزيز نفود طيران السياسي والعسكري
والاقتصادي في العراق من جانبها اصدرت
وزاره وزاره العراقيه تعميم الى الشركات
العراقيه المتخصصه للمشاركه في مشاريع
النصفي والغاز
قالت الامم المتحده ان بعض برامج المساعده
في افغانستان توقفت مؤقتا وذلك بسبب حظرته
حركه الطالبان على العاملات في مجال
الاغاثه محاضره من ان العديد
على الارجح وفي بين المشتركه المراه
نشاط او مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعض الفاصل
دعوات لتظاهرات غاضبه في شمال سوريا ضد
اجتماع بين دمشق وانقره برعايه روسيه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد اطلقنا شطون
السوريون دعوات للتظاهر شمال غربي البلاد
بعد اعلان عن لقاء الثلاثي بين وزراء دفاع
كل من تركيا وسوريا وروسيا في موسكو
السوريه
لاعاده العلاقه مع النظام مستقبلا وكان
مرصد السوريه حقوق الانسان اشار الى ان
احتجاجات شعبيه عامه خارج ضمن مناطق نفي
الفصائل المعارضه في ادلب
بدوره افاده وزير الدفاع التركي خلاص بعد
لقائه مع نظيره السوري علي عباس في موسكو
بحضور وزير الدفاع روسي سيرجي بان
الاجتماع بحث ضمانه تطور ايجابي بشان
الوضع في سوريا وزير الدفاع التركي اضاف
ان بلاده تحترم سياده دول الجوار وهدفها
الاساسيه هو مكافحه الارهاب
مشاهدينا منبرلين يضم الينا الباحث
السياسي رستم محمود اهلا بك سيد محمود
معنا في هذه النشره هناك من يرى ان هذا
الاجتماع الامنيه بين كل من سوريا وتركيا
في روسيا ياتي تمهيدا لمحاصره الاكراد هل
تتفق مع هذا الطرح
ه برعايه روسيه لحد كبير لكن التمارين
الكرديه من امريكا
الى اي توافق يعني يؤدي الى نتيجه واضحه
لان الملفات العالم بين الطرفين الملفات
الثلاثه التي اعلن عنها في مباحثات موسكو
هي شبه مستحيله اعاده اللاجئين
ومحاربه قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه الفعليه
التي لم يتم تسميتها واجراء عمليه سياسيه
مستدامه في سوريا النظام في سوريا لا يقبل
باي شكل من الاشكال اي عمليه سياسيه
حقيقيه تؤدي الى يعني تغيير الشموليه
السياسيه ولا يمكن لهذه الاطراف يعني
تصالح حزب همم حسب الاتحاد الديمقراطيه
وقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه والاداره الذاتيه
بفعل التغطيه العمريكيه البس
اعاده ثمانيه ملايين سوري سواء اربعه
ملايين من الذين يعيشون في مناطق النفوذ
التركيه واربعه ملايين موجودين في تركيا
هو ابو شباب مستحيل لانعدام اشكال الحياه
في مناطق نفوذ النظاره السوريه
في هذه الحاله ما هي خيارات ايضا بالنسبه
الاكراد مزيد من التنسيق ايضا مع جانب
الامريكي
المنطقه في شمال سوريا السوريه
الى حد بعيد وتكتشف الان له يتم يعني
التفاوض على دمائها وعلى مستقبلها وعلى اي
مستقبل القواعد الاجتماعيه المعاليه
بالنظر الى التجارب السابقه هل الجانب
الامريكي يعتبر حليفا موثوقا للاكراد
باختصار لو سمحت
بالاراده الامريكيه الموضوع يتعلق بطبيعه
منطقه شمال شرق سوريا باعتبارها منطقه
تبوس الامن القومي الامريكيه امنيا
وعسكريا تماما نحن متاكدونا الى امريكا لا
تستطيع ان تتخلى عن هذه المنطقه لان الامر
يعني بس مباشره بقبلها القومي وبالحلفاءها
في الدول الاوروبيه لاجل ذلك كما حدث طوال
اكثر من عشره سنوات لا تستطيع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان تتطلع عسكريه
واستراتيجيه عن شباب سوريا وعن كافه الملف
السوري كما لم تستطيع التخلي عن العراق
وجود عمليه سياسيه مستدامه يكون طرف
الكردي او تكون منطقه شمال سوريا الذي
يعتقد من هنا ملكه لا تستطيع ان تتخلى عن
القطر في كرد او عن الادارسه سوريا وضحت
الفكره شكرا لك من برلين كتا معنا الباحث
السياسي رستم محمود تحياتي
في سياق اخر مشاهدين شدد وزير الخارجيه
تركي مولد تشاوش اوغلو على انقر لن تسمح
اليونان بالتوسع في المياه الاقليميه بحر
ايجا وحظره زوج اوغلو من عواق بما وصفه
بالاستفزازات اليونانيه مشيرا الى انها ما
زالت مستمره في المياه الدوليه
نفرئيس التونسي قيسي سعيد اي تراجع
للحريات او الحقوق في تونس منذ وصوله
للسلطه واتهم من وصفهم بالمتابكين على
حريه التعبير بالمرتزقه
ليس لديهم حريه التفكير منهم مرتزقه هبه ب
40 مليون
وهبتها شركه
لرئاسه الحكومه في سنه 17 او 16
باسمي
اصلاح منظومه الاعلام
وتمتع بها
عدد من من يدعونه
في وسائل الاعلام
مرتزقه
وما يحصل
هذه الايام
من قبل الغارقين حتى النخاع
في الفساد
وفي الخيانه
كل يوم
وكل ساعه على مدار
الليل والنهار
ضربه مؤسسات الدوله وهذه الاوضاع
لا يمكن ان تستمر
ولا يمكن
ان يبقى هؤلاء بدون جسار
في اطار القانون
ولكن لابد من تطبيق القانون
للحفاظ على الدوله
تونسيه واحده
وحكومه واحده
ومن يفعل او من يسرع الى ضرب الدوله من
الداخل
الى ضرب السلم الاهليه
سيتحمل مسؤوليته كامله
وراء القضاه الشرفاء
ان
يتحملوا مسؤولياتهم التاريخيه في هذا
الضرب
التي تعيش تونس
في تونس ايضا مشاهدينا من المقرر ان يمتل
رئيس حركه النهضه راشد الغنوشي اليوم امام
القضاء للتحقيق معه فيما يعرف بقضيه
الجهاز السري لحركه النهضه والذي يتهم
بالوقوف وراء اغتيال معارضين سياسيين
وتجسس والتامر على امن الدوله وكان ايضا
قد التحقيق في محكمه اريانه قد اصدر
بطاقتي ايداع بالسجن في حق مسؤولين امنيين
سابقين بوزاره الداخليه وذلك على ذمه
الابحاث في القضيه المذكوره كما وجهتها
الشخصيات الجديده بينها وزير داخليه سابقا
في تونس ايضا مشاهدينا تعتزموا السلطاته
تخفيض دعم المواد الاساسيه بالنسبه لتجاوز
الثلاثين في المئه والمحروقات بنسبه تفوق
خمسه 25% وذلك ضمن الميزانيه العامه 2023
في خطوه لمواجهه عجز ميزانيه الدوله
والضغط على النفقات العموميه
يعملوا فوزي في احد احياء العاصمه
التونسيه في مجال المطاعم وتقديم الاكلات
السريعه منذ ازيد من 30 عاما يقول ان سنه
الحاليه هي الاصعب بنسبه اليها في ظل
الارتفاع الجنوبي للاسعار المواد الاوليه
والاستهلاكيه
اصحاب المهن الصغرى من الارتفاع الاسعار
يتقاسمه معهم المواطن الذي وجد نفسه مضطرا
الى الله في وراء مواد الطاقه والوقوف في
توابير من اجل تحصيل بعض المواد الغذائيه
المفقوده من المحلات والاسواق
المعزه فيه الضوء انا ماشيين في التصعيد
بشي يزيدوا فيه شنو اللي خلوني
حتى شيء تحطه 30 دينار وتروح الرقابه
الاساسيه بنسبه تفوق الثلث وسيشهد دعم
المحروقات تراجعا بالنسبه تفوق الربوع
رفضته منظمات المجتمع المدنيه وبررته
الحكومه بالظرفيه الاقتصاديه الصعبه محليا
والوليا
هناك ارتفاع متواصل في كل المواد وفي كل
الخدمات وخاصه بارتفاع عملها ثمن
المحروقات اكيد منها بقيه
المكونات
ترفع منها ترفع في الكلفه وبالتالي هذا
يازم الوضع شرائح كثيره من المجتمع كنا
نخشى عن الشرائح الضعيفه اليوم حتى شرائح
المتوسطه اصبحت بتبيعه العين مهدده كذلك
وتعمل تونس على تحقيق نسبه نمو في حدود
واحد فاصل ثمانيه بالمئه سنه القادمه عبر
تفعيلي عدد من الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه
والحصول على قرض مالي جديد من صندوق النقد
الدولي
بين نظرتي مواد الطاقه والمواد
الاستهلاكيه وغلاء اسعارها وشح الموارد
الماليه للدوله تتواصلوا معاناه التونسيين
الذين تراجعات قدرتهم شراءيه وسطها
تحضيرات من توتر الوضع الاجتماعي وليد عبد
الله العربيه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اعرابه الولايات
المتحده عن بعد
محكمه تركيا اليوم
[تصفيق]
من المقرر ان تؤدي الحكومه الاسرائيليه
برئاسه
القانونيه اليوم امام
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الجديده افكار اليمين
المتطرف الى جانب تجديد السيطره على القدس
المحتله وتوسيع الاستيطان ومحاربه ايران
ويطالب احباب اليمين المتطرفه بمنح الجيش
اكبر في اطار استخدام القوه في الضفه
الغربيه ضد الفلسطينيين
الحقائب الوزاريه الوازنه لحكومه نتنياهو
الناشئه وقعت في قبضه متطرفين يحملون
ايديولوجيات عنصريه يقول الاسرائيليون ان
استسلام ناتن يهوبات واضحا خاصه على
الصعيد الامني بعد منحه سلطات واسعه
لشريكيه بتليلس مودريتش وتمر بني كبير
القسام داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي هذه
الكتله حقيقه وان كانت تتمسح بالصهيونيه
هي ليست كذلك لا تؤمن بالقيم التي اسستت
عليها الحركه الصهيونيه
المساواه بين الرجل والمراه بين المواطنين
بين مكونات الشعب داخل اسرائيل
سيتولى منصبه وزير الامن القومي وسامح
السيطره المباشره على حارس الحدود بحيث
يكون قادرا على التاثير على التعليمات
للقوات في الميدان ويرغب بتوفير الحصانه
للجنود والشرطه الاسرائيليه لاطلاق النار
والذي اعتبره الفلسطينيون اعطاء الجنود
تصريحا غير محدودا للقتل
لا شك في انه اسرائيل اليوم امام مواقع
غريب وغير مضبوط حيث انه مجموعه من
المتطرفين الذين لم يخدموا بالجيش انا جيش
حقيقه لم يتقبلهم بسبب ماضيهم المشاهب في
صباهم يريدون التحكم في المؤسسه العسكريه
واملائه جدتهم المتطرفه والعنصريه على على
الجيش وقوى الامن
الدينيه سيتولى منصب وزيرا في وزاره الامن
وسيطر على الاداره المدنيه وسيكون تعزيز
وتوسيع الاستيطان وتهجير مزيدا من العرب
من اولوياته
على ما يبدو حكومه نتنياهو الناشئه ستؤدي
الى فوض داخليه وتاكلي دعم الناخبين
العلمانيين لحزب اليكود اضافه لتفجير
الوضع الميداني في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
وافسادهم طبقه من علاقات بين اسرائيل
والسلطه الفلسطينيه
لان كل غاصي من القدس
مؤسسه العربيه
اهلا بك يعني بعد يعني بعد قرابه شهرين من
الانتخابات
الاسرائيليه تم تسليم جميع الاوراق
والاتفاقات الائتلافيه بين حزب الكود
والاحزاب الدينيه المتطرفه الاخرى يعني
وستؤدي اليوم الحكومه السابعه والثلاثين
اليمين القانونيه تمام الساعه الحاديه عشر
تحديدا وبذلك ستبدا هذه الحكومه ولايتها
بشكل رسمي لاننا نتحدث ايضا عن الاتفاقات
الائتلافيه بين همم الكود والصهيونيه
الدينيه وذلك تتضمن الموافقه على اقرار
مشروع يجيز سحب المواطنه وايضا ان كان
لهذا الفلسطيني حامل جواز الاسرائيلي او
حتى انه همم بما كانت مقيم في هذه الدوله
سحب هذه
المواطنه او مكانه مقيم من الفلسطيني اذا
قام بتنفيذ عمليه همم على خلفيه قوميه
ونفيه الى الضفه الغربيه او قطاع غزه او
ابعاده عن اسرائيل كما ان الاتفاق ينص على
تعزيز الاستيطان في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
وايضا في النقب جنوب البلاد وايضا نحن
نتحدث عن الاستيطان في الجولان السوري
المحتل يعني نحن كمان ايضا عفوا نتحدث عن
زياده رواتب عناصر همم جيش الاسرائيلي
يعني بطبيعه الحال هناك قوانين عنصريه همم
اسرائيليه همم يريد هذه الاحزاب تنفيذها
في اسرائيل ولكن التخوفات الرئيسيه هي حول
همم قرارات او قانون يطلق عليه فقره
التغلب وهو يعني تغليب قرارات الكنيست على
قرارات الحكومه الاسرائيليه العليا يعني
في طبيعه الحال كانت ال او او القوانين
بشكل عام الحكومه العليا تستطيع الغاء
قانون قام بسنه الكنيست ولكن هذا ما يزعج
الاحزاب ال الصهيونيه اليمنيه حاليا وهم
يريدون احداث يعني تغيير في هذه القرارات
ويريدون ان الكنيسه تكون اعلى حتى من
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه وهذا ايضا
يعني عديدا من الاشكاليه اول باول القدس
شهد موقع تويتر قطاع كبيرنا حاله دون وصول
عشرات الالاف من مستخدمين على مستوى
العالم الى المنصه هو افاده الذي يتبع
حاله القطاع الانترنت بان اكثر من 10,000
مستخدم الولايات المتحده ونحو 2500
اليابان وقرابه 2015 من بريطانيا
لم يتمكنوا من تسجيل الدخول الى حساباتهم
عبر اجهزه الكمبيوتر المكتبيه او المحموله
فضلا عن الهاتف المحمول وياتي هذا
الانقطاعه بعد ايام من اغلاق احد مراكز
بيانات الشركه في ولايه كاليفورنيا
في مدينه تعز مشاهدينا تقف قلعه القاهره
على اعلى قمه جبل صبر ثاني اعلى جبل في
شبه الجزيره العربيه القلعه التي كان
شهيده على عده عصور
تعاني اليوم من الهجمه الحوثيه وخلقها
سياحيا بفعل حصار على المدينه
قلعه القاهره في مدينه تعز تتربى على قمه
جبل صبر الشاهق منذ القرن الثاني عشر
الميلادي تحفه معماريه فريده ومعلم تاريخي
لم يشفع لها ذلك فباتت في مرمى نيران
ميليشيا الحوثي تعرضت القلعه الى قصف
منهج مباشر
[موسيقى]
تعرضت اجزاء كبيره من القلعه بما يقارب
80% الى التدمير الاسوار مفككه
اثر التاريخ بادا واثر الحوثيين ايضا فاها
لمدينه تعز المحاصره لا يجدون متنفسسا الا
في هذه القلعه
الوحيد في مدينه تعز مابوش مكان مابش اي
مكان نتنزه فيه غير هذا المكان سابقا كانت
القلعه مزارا وقبله سياحيه لاسيما
الخارجيه الا ان القلعه محرومه من زوارها
فالحوثيون يطبقون الحصار على المدينه
جففت القلعه سياحيا لكنها صامده منذ
ثمانيه قرون واليوم تكتب فصلا يمنيا اخر
من تاريخ البلاد
ولا مشاهدينا الاخبار الاقتصاد مع زميله
النادي
اهلا وسهلا بكم
هي بالوقت الحاضر مع الاشاره الى ان
الصوره العالميه سلبيه بعض الشيء ولكن سوق
الاسهم السعوديه على بعض الارتفاع ذكر انه
مؤشر السوق السعودي وصل الى مستويات
1000033 نقطه كان هذا القاع الذي سجلناه
بالثاني عشر من ديسمبر منذ ذلك الحين هناك
بعض تحسن شهر ديسمبر لازال على تراجعات
باثنين بالمئه اكيد نحن باخر جلسات هذا
الشهر على الاسهم المتحركه في السوق
السعوديه اولا هذه الطرحات الاوليه التي
ادرجت بالسوق مؤخرا واللي انخفضت اسعارها
عن سعر ومن تبعها عم بتوصل طارق التراجع
كان صاحب الطرح العام الاول يعني 99 ريال
تتداول تحت ال 95 بالوقت الحاضر نفس الامر
السيف غاليري وكابلات الرياض اليوم المزيد
من النزول على هذه الاسهم انه القناطر على
بعض لاسهم الاخرى التي نتبعها عليها اخبار
طيبه اشترت حصه الاولى بمدينه المعرفه
واليوم عم نشوف بعض الارتفاع على طيبه
مدينه المعرفه صفوا لها على سبب تقول انها
ستسجل ارباح همم تحت بند ارادات اخرى ب 39
مليون همم ريال وارباح راسماليه ب 42
مليون ريال تدخل كلها بقوائم ربع رابع من
العام الحالي لانقاذره على بعض الاسهم
الاخرى التي نتبعها عليها اخبار اليوم
اسمنت الجنوب اعطتنا ابديت على همم خط
انتاج جديد تقول انها تلقت عروض من شركات
للتنفيذ وتدرس هذه العروض السهم على
ارتفاع سابك للمغذيات الزراعيه همم تقول
حقا لخبر بمطلعه على 2022 انها عم تستحوذ
على 49% من شركه اي جي
الان تقول انها ستنتهي من عمليه الاستحواذ
والاثر المالي سيظهر بالنصف الاول من 2023
على قبائل انها السهم على ارتفاع دوائيه
في وقعت اتفاقيه اسئله ائتمانيه مع صعب
650 مليون ريال وزجاج توزيعات نقديه ب 50
ثانيه من الالعاب هذه الصوره بالسوق
السعوديه هذه الاسهم القياديه الرياض
والراجحي على بعض الارتفاع والاهلي كذلك
فاذا القطاع المصري في يرتد اليوم صعودا
وايضا سابكم عادا لاحظوا معادن اثنين
بالمئه من الارتفاع نكتفي بهذا القدر
العوده اليك احمد
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اغاني الهلال الاحمر
السوداني نزوحا 5000 من المواطنين
السودانيين في جنوب دارفور في السودان
هذه توقعات القبليه جاءت لتفاقيما معاناه
سكان المنطقه من الفقر
بكاء على ما فقد ممزوج بفرحه النجاه
وغيرهما من سكان دارفور الذين لجاوا الى
محليه بليل بحثا عن الامن الذي فقدوه في
ديارهم منذ دلاع الاشتباكات بين قبيله
التاج وقبائل العربيه الاسبوع الماضي
والذي اسفر عن عدد من القتل والجرحى لكن
النزوح نفسه ليس بالسهل نظرا لنقص
الامكانيات
وانا لما ساكن
يا جماعه
من النازحات فليس ثمه ما يقومون به لتحسين
الاوضاع فقدنا اموالنا فقدنا كل شيء
[موسيقى]
الظروف المناخيه اتت لتفاقيمه معاناه من
نزح من سكان جنوب دارفور مهما حاولوا ان
يزينوا اوقاتهم فان الفاقه هي واقعهم
والجوع يتربص بهم ماء ينفذ ما بهذه القدور
من طعام
قال رئيس
بلاده هو الحفاظ على السلام باكملها الى
الامام جاء ذلك خلال لقاء مع مساعده
حواجز الطرق في المنطقه الشماليه الحدوديه
المطربه وهذه صور مباشره من الاجواء في
شمال
جندي وشرطي اغلبهم من قواتنا الخاصه لكنني
اعتقد ان هدفنا يجب ان يكون الحفاظ على
السلام
باكملها الى الامام اعلم ان شعبنا لن يرضى
ابدا حتى يتاكد من انه يعيش في صربيا ولا
يقال له انه يعيش في دوله اخرى
مشاهدينا نتابع اذا هذه الصور المباشره من
الشمالي كوسوفو على خلفيه التوترات بين
صربيا وشمال او امم دوله كوسوفو ايضا على
خلفيه قيام بعض العناصر في شمال كوسو ومن
الصربي اغلاق بعض الطرق والمناطق
تحولت مدينه
الجليديه بعد ان غطى الطبقات الثلوج
المنازل من مع استمرار العاصفه الثلجيه
التي تضرب وكانت الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
وهذه وقت مع ابرز الصور والاقطات لشهر
اكتوبر هذا العام متابع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وفي الخطاب مشاهدينا نذكر بالعناوين
صواريخ الروسيه
في ايران تخطط ال 500 بينهم 69 طفلا
رئيسه
التحقيق في قضيه الجهاز السري للاخوان
نتنياهو يقدم حكومته الجديده الى البرلمان
اليوم للمصادقه بعد اربع سنوات من
التجاربات السياسيه